[Music]
in fighting words news submitted by
Stella from Phoenix this is the one
question you should never ask your
partner do I look fat
no I taught him well before he used to
say yes of course you're supposed to ask
your partner yeah but before he should
say yes to ask me anymore yeah we're
both learning I see you can't say yeah
no no the truth the problem is that Bart
told ya that is the forget I learn to
always lie enough please so the question
that we're talking about here is are you
mad at me [ __ ] as [ __ ] yes are you mad
at me it's like but girls per se no no
no no no one should ask this to their
partner I asked them the reason why I
ask is because she looks really pissed
so I just want to know if I [ __ ] up or
not guess what she is hold on I got an
answer for you no idea I'm gonna help
you listen from you for you you're
asking that question because you feel
that you are trying to get to the bottom
of what's going on with her and like
what's happening I'm concerned for you
yes yes but the way that is translated
you make it about you you're making it
about you that to you I know Jim I can
you stop asking it like that cuz you're
are you mad at me exactly are you mad at
me right now are you you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you I care I care about
what you're doing to me is what it
sounds like and not what's going on with
you how are you what can I do
so you know how to be a good human so
you're prioritizing yourself and your
feelings over finding out what's
happening Department I see yes that's
what's happening here
this is stuffing me the [ __ ] teacher
in school tacitly selfish
yeah and it's aggressively annoying I
see teach that on a podcast all the time
yep yeah ends up a lot in a vise
questions so what's happening here is
it's an emotional self-centeredness
masquerading as concern
he thinks you're just talking to him I
really have no different than where are
you I was looking for you you didn't
tell me where you were I didn't know if
you were safe its you're making about
you you're acting fake concern for them
but you really just wanna keep tabs on
that basically so then the last thing
anyone wants to do is have to have to
deal with more emotional labor when
they're already faced let me [ __ ]
jail I don't want to explain myself
yeah so you end up having to coddle
someone while you're pissed
oh good time I tell him this all the
time he's a big [ __ ] you don't explain
any of this are you okay but that's
actually what they're writing here so
instead here's some options cuz it makes
it about them yeah you can say it you
can ask is everything okay am i right
and sensing that something is on your
mind how are you really
those are beautiful yeah so like you
know you're so asking your partner to
assure you that you are not in trouble
first undermines their feelings by
prioritizing your fragile ego over them
and that's the truth
cuz it's like it's like hey I feel
guilty can you make can you give me
reassurance that I'm not like I actually
care about what's happening right can
you see you're upset can you call me
please yes so then you end up you end up
having to service someone while you're
pissed instead of paying service but
then you do this [ __ ] where it's
like it's a nice asses she's mad at me
and that she got mad
yeah you sit backwards on that chair so
people see Steve Iceman or don't even or
he's too cool how do you know he's ice
cold they're also saying that by being
genuinely invested in their feelings and
give and being patient enough to try to
discover what's happening that is so
attractive and that will help your
relationship by like times a million
because you're showing that you're there
for your partner it's a partnership not
instead of being like can you service me
and my ego right now thanks for teaching
me all this yeah could he use like ten
years ago ten years what's crazy as I've
told them this summer
not in this articulate way I've
literally said so you want me to get out
of how I feel so I can figure out how
you feel and make you feel better it's
what I've literally thought what you
said I'm like okay I'm gonna get it can
I predict what Bart said to that he's
like yeah no you know what he says he's
like you're supposed to be more
emotionally intelligent than me you
should be teaching me they do it again
it's your responsibility the more
emotionally intelligent person putting
your emotions on hold Joe fix my
emotions AK yeah I know I'm emotionally
dumb so I'm like if it comes to other
[ __ ] that I know I'm like hey well you
follow me but this [ __ ] I'm trying to
learn so I'll follow you yeah because I
know how you saying do it for me right I
don't want to learn you do it I don't
want to learn no he does want to learn
but what's the way he's vocalizing it is
not yeah but I'm a [ __ ] badass look at
what I got it but he's doing good we're
doing I don't think anyone's like oh
well yeah you're right I want him now
what they see is a baby who can walk now
sometimes I still fall everybody steps
but what's tough is he's always down and
do the work any put so that's the only
thing that matters because if you didn't
put in the word I hate him he was
against it and arguing with you like
that's completely different than someone
who's willing to learn but he just
doesn't have the tools cuz he didn't
grow up with it I think that's why uh
it's it's it's really charming but also
it sucks to be his wife it's hard
because it's it's because I'm kind of
like I was in the same boat like and I
still AM we're like it's just a lot of
things I didn't grow with it doesn't
come second nature yeah yeah it's not
that I'm incapable of understanding the
social dynamic or feeling or
communication style it's just not ever
present in my life or never was you it's
not the tip of your tongue no so then
it's like a brand new language we learn
how we hit 30 something it's almost like
being a part of a whole different
culture and other people might have
normal like cultural mores or like ways
of communicating where you'd speak that
language so you accept you expect that
people understand this and when someone
does it
you start looking down at them and I
think that's the hard part is when
people start looking down at you for not
knowing you should know already all
these that's what they prevents you from
even trying cuz it's scary
that's where the pry kind of comes up or
like oh well people are weak and
emotional anyway do you know what it's
crazy I'm gonna share with you so
recently I had like this epiphany where
Tiffany Tiffany here we go 2020 I knew
you and it's been amazing
so my epiphany was that in our marriage
because Casey's being on the camera in
our marriage we in our entire
relationship we have had a lot of like
turbulence oh yeah a lot of couples have
and it's been a lot of like Carol yeah
I'm playing no let me explain so we have
had a lot of like turbulence right and
it's been this whole time of like one
side being the one that's kind of like
causing it and
the other side being the are you [ __ ]
serious this is happening again I mean I
wonder who's woohoo in this is the one
that's saying are you [ __ ] serious is
happening again ends up becoming very
entitled in the relationship and then so
like and then what ends up happening is
that once at its height entitlement it
is there then the other person ends up
being like well oh [ __ ] I'm doing this
oh [ __ ] well let me try to get better
and then the entitlement kicks in and
it's like also now you want to get
better so that's not gonna help and
that's actually what I realize what was
happening with that I'd stay so like oh
like oh [ __ ] this is where I've been
[ __ ] up in the equation it's awesome
and so I've been more mindful of being
more like supportive and nurturing
instead of being like well let the [ __ ]
you should know this like what you're it
yeah yeah well sure the thing though
it's it's it's it's a script that you
tell yourself and perspective that you
create of other human beings so like
over time there's resentment and baggage
that we create toward each other and
ourselves right so Bart has a script
right now that says I am unemotional I
am this I am whatever right which it's
not the case because there are cases
where he acts out of a certain way and
you can be that way right but in that
specific situation we all go back to our
script where I started to believe that
oh I don't have empathy I don't have
this I'm incapable of being romantic
which is completely wrong because so
right because I am capable of those
feelings in the right situation and I
can express these things and I can do
these things and understand them like in
your situation I'm guilty of what Bart
did exactly but seeing from the outside
I'm like oh yeah I totally get what's
going on there in that situation you
have to be more loving and and and not
self-serving
you have to be more about them it's easy
to do but there's a routine that you
guys created in your relationship where
you go back to that default and it's
like that's your role this is my role so
it's true right so then I realize that
oh [ __ ] dude like we all are fluid and
capable of being these other things but
once you write yourself or you have an
image of someone yeah
it's our excuse - it's your excuse yeah
yeah so then we have to try our best not
to look at our partner the same exact
way even when in friendships or whatever
right and give people a chance to learn
and do better each time
pathetic it's like a huge thing because
once you have that empathy it's like oh
well I see that you're trying so why am
I gonna push you further away from you
because you're hurt yeah because no
serving part yeah because I'm hurt first
you did it again you violated my it can
be a water drinker you like I just wanna
keep putting him in a box of not a
person that drinks water yeah you take
him out of that box and then maybe he
can drink that water and prove me wrong
boy yes three you drink so much water
he's gonna become the Iceman one day
well you need water the ice yeah so just
again do you overheat every night
because you don't have enough water how
do I sweat if I have no water in there
oh yeah well he will eventually not
overheat or anything and anyone more
jealous but they don't have a cool
nickname and so this is so so going back
to what itwhat where I came up with his
epiphany right it's like check this out
so yes Epiphany Joe so why is it that so
we're not being fake when we act
differently in different situations this
is all different aspects of who we are
so for example in a job interview or
acting job interview Joe right in JK
news Joe or [ __ ] in like when we're with
our significant other we have a
different face for each occasion and
some people will say you're being a
fraud with multiple different facets
that's not who you are but it actually
is who the [ __ ] you are and some people
bring out the best in you and some
people bring out the worst in you so
some people might make you out a
character where you're like this super
[ __ ] romantic person and other people
might completely make you a hateful
angry person or whatever it is right so
that's when I was like oh [ __ ]
everyone's capable of expressing and
learning and doing these different
things
but it depends on the role that you
start to create and solidify within that
dynamic mm-hmm yeah I mean like I've
been saying you could brand yourself and
then you can also fall back on your own
brand as an excuse for why you'll never
change but that's the mistake right
instead of treating people like
three-dimensional human beings who are
capable of change and who are beautiful
you kind of write it off like oh this
person's always this anyway and then
it's just there you're writing them off
literally right yeah and you're not
dealing with it exactly but most most of
most things that I think stay constant
is that people are [ __ ] idiots
[Music]
[Music]